alors si je comprends bien ton frère est
malade et tu n'as pas d'argent pour les
médicaments c'est ça oui messieurs c'est
ça mon pauvre petit je peux peut-être td
c'est vrai or aux yeux ronds partant ces
bêtes
malheureusement je n'ai pas un sou sur
moi mais peut-être que les spas
réfléchissez rien laissé c'est pas grave
tant pis je me débrouillerai je peux
être une idée pour que tu gagnes de
l'argent mon garçon avec un beau sac
comme le terrain c'est vrai vous voulez
me l'acheter mais si vraiment non pas
moi non mais je connais quelques uns à
bout et si tu es capable de faire
d'autres jolies 5
ça se vend très bien dans les boutiques
du centre ville
toi ça m'étonnerait pas que tu viennes
d'un village près de la frontière
oui monsieur de card un cadeau je
connais car d'où ces jolies par là
s'inquiète pas je vais t'aider
je vais aller à la pharmacie d'acheter
tous les médicaments dont tu as besoin
tu me remboursera plus tard avec
l'argent que tu gagneras un vent dans
ton sac alors mon garçon tu préfère
rester ici avec ton ami le boucher ou
venir avec moi chercher les médicaments
pour soigner ton frère